if you don't know what i'm about to
share with you you're never going to
scale your business
fundamentally business is a an
action an asset that expands based on
multiplication
we're doing the same thing over and over
and over again so repetition and scale
are fundamental to how a business grows
and so you have to understand how to
scale yourself
through others it's taken me a very long
time to understand a very simple concept
and i'm going to share it with you
if for some reason in your company right
you're
not getting the outcome from the
employees that you want then it is one
of these three things that's the issue
and i believe that simplicity you know
simple scales fancy fails and so i like
to keep my framework simple
and the way that i discovered this was
actually through reading andy grove's
book
high output management really really
highly recommend and he's one of the
all-time best operators you know in
of all time he's the goat of operations
and he posited that there's two
things fundamentally that every manager
should do and adding one-third
uh one one other piece to this has been
my personal experience and so i'm adding
these two together
if you don't know who we are my name is
oxford mosey i own a portfolio companies
that does
uh just under 85 million a year we've
done 120 million in the last three years
and i have nothing to sell you so let's
rock you into it so
how to scale yourself so the first
question that i like to ask myself if
somebody is not doing
what i want them to do is do they know
what i want them to do
all right which if they don't then it's
a function of communication so if
someone doesn't
is not doing what i want them to do the
first question i ask is like did you
know what i wanted you to do
was it clear and one of the rules that
we have is it's not written it never
happened
all right so if you're giving a
directive to somebody say hey can you do
this for me
that's where you follow up with slack or
you fought with a son or you fought with
an email because if it doesn't exist in
the digital world it doesn't
there's no record of it then it's like
it didn't happen all right and so one of
the rules of thumb is
if someone's not doing something the
first thing asks is do you know what i
wanted you to do
and then did i personally follow up with
that via email slack
asana or whatever tools you use to run
your business
if that's true if that has happened then
i follow to the next thing which is
survey training do they know how to do
what i want them to do so
they may know what i want them to do
because i communicated
adequately i documented it i put it in
asana i put it in an email i put it
whatever in slack so that they knew
after the conversation even though i
told them that what i expected them to
do and by when
right but if they're like i didn't know
how to do it
then i would say okay well how can i how
can i help you with this do i need to
provide a training for you do i need to
buy a course for you do i need to hop on
a call and explain it to you
does another employee need to train you
like does your manager need to train you
like what needs to happen here for you
to understand how to do
what i want you to do all right so these
are the first two levels of scaring
yourself
first you have clear understanding of
what it is that you want them to do and
i'm telling you this is the framework
that i use when i'm thinking through
this stuff like
if someone is not executing i just have
to think to myself i always assume it's
my fault
and then i think okay well they either
just don't know what i want them to do
or they don't know how i want them to do
it or which leads me to the third one
if they know what i want them to do and
they know how to do it
then why aren't they doing it which
comes to motivation right
and if they're not motivated then i have
to figure out why now most of the time
it comes from a couple of things
and i would say these are the most
common ones that i have dealt with the
first is that they don't understand
why it's important within the larger
context of the company they just feel
like they're a cog within the business
and they don't understand
what this contributes to the business
right one of the number one feelings
that people or employees will have
is they feel like what their their work
doesn't matter and that's what creates
you know meaningless work busy work
people who just try and look busy when
they're not actually doing anything
and it's because they don't understand
why you even have their role
and that means that a lot of times it's
because their manager or whatever didn't
do a good job communicating it was like
this is our function within the business
this is what happens if we don't exist
this is what the experience is like if
if we do a good job
this is what happens this is the result
and just about every function of the
business can be tied
uh to how it contributes to the bottom
line even if you're a more support or
operations role
like i.t if we didn't have you know
information systems we wouldn't know
where our tracking is for anything and
we couldn't make good decisions and the
business relies on high quality
decisions
if we're in marketing we wouldn't be
getting new business in if we're in
sales we wouldn't be transacting if
we're in customer service we'd be
getting
chargebacks and people wouldn't be happy
right we have to tie and make sure that
everyone understands how you contribute
to the bottom line why it's important
that's the first level of understanding
for motivation here right the second
level is making sure that they're
actually
bought into the vision of the company
what's the mission what are we trying to
accomplish who are we trying to help
what problem the world are we solving
this is something that i've you know i
had to learn as our company scaled is
that
some of that soft you know woo-woo like
whatever uh
culture stuff is actually really
important right especially as you scale
because when you scale
service especially does anyone know what
the two things that you scale
are tell you what they are it's culture
and training that is what happens when
you scale decision making
right that is how you scale decision
making is culture and training
and the culture is going to come from
telling people what they need to do and
why we do it and the training
is there to make sure that they know how
to do it when the time comes and they
are motivated to do so
right and so you can look at a lot of an
employee and figure out
if someone's not doing it sometimes they
have two of the three so an employee for
example that knows what to do
and is motivated to do it and but not
doing it because they don't know how
they'll usually pretend that they're
busy because they're so ashamed of the
fact that they don't know what they're
doing
but they really like love the company
and want to help right but a lot of
times people don't advocate for
themselves
and so we have to make sure they know
how now for example an employee who
uh is motivated and has the training but
doesn't know what you want them to do
a lot of times it's just paralyzed or
starts executing on things that are not
relevant
i've had this happen so many times it
like drives me nuts someone's
someone knows who knows how to do what
we want them to do and they know why
it's important but they're executing on
things that are not priorities
so they start doing extra work because
they're motivated and they know how to
do stuff that's valuable
but it's not contributing to anything
that's moving the company forward right
they're not doing they're not executing
things in alignment with where we're
going as a company
right and then the third combination
would be somebody who knows what to do
and they know how to do it but they're
not motivated
and this is typically i would say the
the worst scenario which is where
somebody
just feels worthless and so these people
tend to check out they're not working
they're trying to avoid
confrontation as much as possible and
usually they're probably looking for
other jobs
and so for me i try to think most of the
times they're not going to have none of
them right they're going to have one or
two
of these things hopefully right it's not
like they don't know what to do they
don't know how to do it they
don't know why they're even there i've
had it happen and it's horrible but like
most times there's two of the three that
are there and you just have to figure
out which of the other three is missing
and that is ultimately how you can scale
decision making and scale yourself
within the company
that is how you scale companies i hope
you found this valuable click subscribe
use this framework when you're not
getting what you want from your team
think about one it's my fault two which
of these three things missing
and how can i solve it keep being
awesome the reason i made this channel
is because a lot of people are broke and
i don't want you to be one of them hit
subscribe and i'll see you next video